good morning everyone thanks for coming
in on a Friday morning especially with
the long weekend coming up we're gonna
pick up pick up where we left off
yesterday and so if you recall we were
looking at an iterative approach to
solving the 8 Queens problem and in case
you've forgotten in the I guess
intervening 20 hours the the 8 Queens
problem which is a specific instance of
n Queens this you have a chessboard and
I won't draw out all the squares there
which is obviously an 8x8 board and you
want to place 8 Queens on this on this
board such that no two Queens attack
each other and we looked at the
different data structures to solve this
the naive data structure would be to
represent at the board as a
two-dimensional list and so you end up
having an 8 by 8 if you have a chess
board for the 8 Queens problem we'd
looked at a 4 by 4 for starters and and
then after that we looked at compressing
that representation down to a 1
dimensional list where let's say you had
a 5 by 5 boat because I got 5 entries
here you essentially think of you
exploit the fact that they can be at
most one queen on any given column and
you say I'm going to represent the
position of that Queen using a single
number that varies from in this case 0
through 4 big if you have a 5 by 5 boat
and you put that in here so a minus 1
would represent this being empty a tube
would represent a queen in the in the
second column in this position over here
etc etcetera so with this more compact
representation it turns out that the
conflict check becomes pretty
straightforward and if you remember our
conflict check is incremental in the
sense that what you're going to do is
assume that that Queens have already
been placed in some number of columns I
mean could be 0 in this case it's 2 and
you can you're gonna try and check to
see if when a third Queen is placed on
the third column number two whether it
conflicts with the existing Queens but
you don't have to worry about the checks
associated with the existing Queens
because you've already taken care of
that right so that's the incremental
nature of this check and I won't go over
this code again but this does the check
associated with ensuring that when you
place the Queen on a on a given column
it it checks the diagonals that's the
most interesting part and you you you
put you put a queen here you need to
check this and you need to check that
and in this case obviously there's a
conflict and because they're two
diagonals that's why you have the ABS
the absolute value over there and you're
exploiting the fact that at the diagonal
is a diagonal of the square and how much
you move up should be how much you move
to the right or down left what have you
and the other check is simply ensuring
that I when you look at the particular
column and you see the the the number
current is the particular column the
number associated with that particular
column shouldn't be repeated in some
other column because that would imply
that you if you if you saw a 2 and a 2
here obviously that would imply that you
have you have two queens on the same row
okay and you can't have that right so so
that's the story and we decided to use
iteration because at this point in time
you know nothing else in terms of
control flow I know that's not the case
but we assume that and and so you end up
having this this this ugly
code associated with eight eight loops
eight nested loops that does this
incremental enumeration so board zero
being one implies that you're putting
I'm sorry but zero being I implies that
you're taking the first column and
you're iterating the positions of the
Queen in the rows of the first column
and so on and so forth and if you go
ahead and run this which we did last
time you end up getting ninety two
different solutions to the 8 Queens
problem and as I mentioned there's only
12 distinct once if you take rotation
and reflection into account and each of
these is a legitimate solution that
needs to be translated into the picture
that you see here by essentially taking
this data structure that you see seven
becomes the Queen in the corner left
corner etc alright so we absolutely do
not want it public well we won't want to
publish this code I guess I'm in effect
I'm doing it but you would not want to
claim authorship of this code especially
if you know about the programming
technique that's called recursion all
right so that's really what we're going
to do today we're going to look at a
couple of different puzzles we'll finish
up for the N Queens puzzle fairly
quickly and we'll look at how we could
use recursion which is an algorithmic
paradigm as well as a programming
paradigm to solve challenging problems
and that there's really two classes at
least of recursive algorithms and you're
going to see both of those today
the first one is n Queens and I'll get
to the second one when we get to the
second one all right so our goal now is
to take that ugly code and make it
pretty and before I get into that I want
to show you a simpler example of
iteration versus recursion okay and this
is about as simple as it gets while
still being interesting from an
algorithmic standpoint so a greatest
common divisor
euclid's the age-old algorithm to
compute the greatest common divisor and
you see that 2 line 3 line what have you
iterative algorithm up there that
corresponds to taking the pair of
numbers obviously m and n that have that
you need to compute the greatest common
divisor for and all you do is assign m
to n and n becomes M mod n and this is
I'm not going to explain why this
algorithm is correct or anything like
that I'm not particularly interested in
that what I'm much more interested in is
ensuring that you understand that the
iterative algorithm is is the same as a
recursive one but recursive one gets you
the correct answer
if you assume that the iterative
algorithm is correct and vice versa and
that's really what this is about right
so so we won't argue if Euclid is
correct or not but the point here is I
you could have translated well you did
translate this iterative algorithm into
a recursive one and there's a couple of
things I want you to keep in mind when
you look at recursive code or when and
it certainly when you write recursive
code and it's much easier pointing this
out in a simple example like this right
so that the first off when I say when we
say recursion and I should probably said
this a little bit earlier recursion is
something calling itself so you can say
a function f calling itself that's kind
of the simple case we also consider if
you have F calling G which calls F then
you know that is recursive as well and
so you could have arbitrary structures
that correspond to nested recursion
we're really only going to be looking at
functions in at least in this lecture
where you have it as a single function f
calling itself right which is exactly
the case for our GCD the recurs
gcd that you see here you see a call our
GCD inside of our GCD and you know this
function is recursive sometimes you may
look at a function and you don't see
that immediate syntactic evidence that
the function is recursive but it may be
recursive because of nested recursion f
calling G more complicated recursion
right so this is clearly a recursive
function our GCD and two things that you
need to look for if you want to write
correct recursion I mean this is not
sufficient to write correct recursion
but necessary and in particular when I
say correct recursion I want it to be
non terminating so the problem with
something calling itself is you think of
it as you know there's some sort of
cycle and you absolutely need to break
out of the cycle otherwise you'll be in
the cycle forever right you could call
something which calls something what's
called something that that goes on your
program isn't going to terminate so you
always want to be careful when you write
recursive code that there's a base case
right there's a termination condition so
there should be some part of the code
where if certain conditions are
satisfied you're not making a recursive
call all right that is what I would
consider the base case that really comes
from induction and from the mathematics
of recursion you want to have a base
case and then the recursion is really
the inductive step all right
that doesn't make too much sense don't
worry about it it's you can think of it
think tactically look for a path in the
code where you don't see our GCD inside
of our GCD and you can clearly see that
in the if M mod n equals equals zero
return n right so that's that's really
the so you want to have what we call the
base case
where
function returns um that's not enough
because you don't quite know if you're
going to get to that base case or not
you're going to call this function with
some arguments and you want to get some
sense that the arguments are shrinking
as you go and in or it could even be the
other way around the arguments may may
increase and once you grow beyond a
certain threshold you fire off on the
return without making the recursive call
right so so so this this notion of the
arguments becoming smaller is very a
common in the case of the algorithmic
paradigm that we'll be following in this
class where we're going to take large
problems like eight Queens or n Queens
and go to n minus one Queens and n minus
two Queens and divide and conquer
which is another paradigm that we look
at as you can see from the name is
taking a big problem and making it
smaller right so it's really for the
most part you're going to essentially
have a situation where you're going to
say that the arguments I to the function
I should be smaller in some sense and
smaller could mean bigger okay I mean
it's just a definitional thing I mean
the point is when you get to the base
case usually you're saying as you can
see in this base case you're saying when
when it comes down to the fact that a
particular condition is satisfied in
this case it's a relationship between m
and n and if that's zero then we return
n but in other cases it just might be
when you get to a one queen problem
you're you're done right I mean you put
you have no choice you got this one by
one board and you got to put your queen
on it and you know obviously that might
create a conflict but you're done right
I mean there's nothing there's no two
things about it if you have a one queen
problem there's only one step you you
put your queen down right so that's kind
of where we're at with respect to the
puzzles that we're going to be doing in
this class where you're you're going to
shrink things down right so in that
sense in a smaller makes it would
would mean smaller right it's not
necessarily in quotes so that makes
sense any questions at all about syntax
or anything that you see on the board
here alright good so now I I'm ready to
show you what the end Queen's code looks
like one of the other problems of course
with the the eight Queens code is that I
it only works for eight Queens and it
doesn't work for nine right and I that's
annoying so you'd like to have a
procedure that takes n as an argument
and works for N equals four N equals
eight and eventually I mean you could
run those on N equals 20 and it will
finish I'll show you but that there is
an exponential relationship between
runtime and N okay because it's just a
complicated problem there's a lot of
combinations so you do not want to run
this code for more than n equals 25
right it would it hasn't completed I
think I at some point I did a analysis
on how long it would take for N equals
30 and you know wasn't something I
wanted to wait for I mean my computer
would have would have gotten old and
died before it you know the program came
back right so which is a reasonable
experiment you know to carry out but I
like my computer I'm kind of annoyed
with it because it's because of the new
operating system but I generally like it
so you can see that we're going to use
exactly the same framework we're going
to use the same conflict routine no
conflicts routine there's no change
there no change in data structures it's
that there's no change in really even
the incremental strategy that we're
following but we can take that iterative
code and turn it into this pretty code
that is for about five lines right or
seven lines what have you right and so
you can see again that if you look at
that code I mean it's not that much more
complicated and there's more going on in
there
it is it there's more going on because
it's a more interesting problem at some
level then Jesus
but it passed the same characteristics
in terms of having a base case and it's
actually an easy one to look at and it
it also has a property to hear where the
argument to the end Queens is going to
be one less than what the caller
function has as its argument right
because you're going column by column
and you're taking away in this case
you're not necessarily going to a 7x7
really it's not that you're going from 8
by 8 to 7 by 7 you're going from 8 by 8
to 7 by 8 right you have you have one
less column you still have to work with
other all the rows right so so that's
really what's going on out here if
current equals size so what's happening
is current is actually incrementing
right so you're you know you're moving
and what is remaining is becoming
smaller and current starts with so if
you look at n Queens here it says n
Queen's a size and our Queens which is
this routine here
it sets current to be to be zero and
sizes of course whatever you gave n
Queens which could be 8 or 20 and
finally at you the if you look at this
part of the code I you get to the point
where you run out of columns when
current equals size and at this point
you you put all the Queens down and that
things haven't fallen apart you haven't
returned false and therefore you're done
right so if when you get to that you
know quote ninth column you're off the
board and and you're done and all of the
existing Queens the eight Queens that
were put on the board didn't conflict
with each other right that's kind of how
it works and then over here you've taken
your your eight loops that were in the 8
Queens problem or the four loops in the
4 Queens problem and and you've gone off
and and turned it into one loop but and
the reason that works is because our
Queens is calling our Queens out here
all right so that's your recursive call
so and then the argument here is current
plus one and it's getting closer and
closer to size as you go around which
means that it's effectively getting
smaller okay
what you're working with is getting
smaller right so if you if you kind of
look at what happens here this is you
can trace the execution of this and this
is worthwhile doing and I'll put it I'll
put this in the notes and you can look
at it for a 4x4 but in general its word
if you're confused about recursion
it's absolutely worthwhile to trace the
execution for small arguments and and
figure out exactly when things are
terminating and when when things are
being called recursively and this is
simply a single call if you look at you
are looks like it's a single call but
how many how many because there's only
one instance of our Queens but if you
look at the code how many calls would I
possibly make I if I were sitting with
an 8 Queens problem and and I started
with with size equals 8 then in that
very first I invoke our Queens with with
current equals 0 and size equals 8 how
many our Queens calls will the first our
Queens make how many times would would
potentially make that so if I look at
the branching here and and I say this is
our Queens and this has current equals 0
and size equals 8 the way you want to
think about this from us from a tracing
standpoint is is you're making calls so
our cue our Queens is calling our Queens
right I and at obviously there's there's
our Queens in the middle of that of that
code over there and so what what is the
breadth here in terms of the number of
calls
someone
how many III trace the code so I in
range eight which means zero to seven
and then I'm going to go off and it's
the very first one so so no conflicts is
going to constantly return it's the
first Queen right so no conflicts is
going to constantly return true right so
I'm going to go inside of the if right
and I'm gonna make that our queens call
right so so I'm gonna have eight
different calls associated with each of
the positions that corresponds to the
Queen on the first column right and and
then each of these you know could
potentially make eight different calls
now potentially I said because it as you
get deeper in the recursion no conflicts
is going to fire false and I may not
make the call right but obviously the
very first one you're gonna make eight
calls right so recursion is scary it in
from a performance standpoint to some
people and and rightly so because things
could explode on you and this goes back
to what I said about twenty five you
know running this with in our size
equals twenty five and so on and so
forth and one of the things that is
worth doing and you have to do this type
of analysis in a classes like six double
O six not a lot of this but because we
don't do exponential algorithms but you
you can look at this tree that is being
generated by these recursive calls and
that you do want to get some sense of
how large this tree is going to become
and we're going to look at a different
class of algorithms most of the
algorithms we're going to look at that
are recursive for the rest of this this
course including the next one that we'll
get to in a few minutes and aren't as
bad as this one in terms of in terms of
computational complexity right but but
n-queens is a hard problem
it needs exhaustive search and there's a
lot of combinations and so it's not a
it's not an efficient algorithm
efficient means polynomial time
something like N squared quadratic and
cubed and so on and this is not
efficient and and the reason for that is
this explosion and the number of
recursive calls right so it's easy to
write
code five lines of code that takes
forever to run it will terminate it's
not that it had an infinite loop in it
but the number of combinations explodes
on you right because of eight and then
eight again for each of these so and and
then you know and so on so you can see
that gets gets pretty large pretty quick
right so all right so I this this code I
is is something that as I said is
essentially the same it's sitting there
computing in Queens 20 okay that's why
it's it's this is not a problem with my
laptop at least as of this moment I
don't think it's a problem with my
laptop okay and so there you go so it n
cleans 20 gave you with this
representation that the representation
that we chose you can try and convince
yourself that this in fact is correct
right I haven't but but that code is so
straightforward
at this point that it it would be if
there was anything wrong with it it'd be
catastrophic ly wrong okay it would just
crash or it would it would returns
anything and so that is one solution
there's many many solutions
unlike the eight Queens case where I I
ran it to completion and all the ninety
two solutions got printed out there's
millions of solutions here so if I just
took out a return statement and let it
run you know this you'd get screens
screen folds of solutions to the twenty
Queens problem because we're not
exploiting rotational or reflected even
if you did that there would be a lot of
solutions but especially given that
we're not exploiting rotational symmetry
and and reflections there's a lot of
solutions okay but that's one of them
right so there you go all right yeah
question
no there's no closed-form solution no I
it's even for the 12 is a concrete
number that in 92 and 12 were enumerated
right so now you could obviously write a
computer program that counted I mean you
didn't have to print this out I mean you
could count the number of solutions to
that twenty Queens problem and you know
you can find that out but then if you
want to do rotations and reflections
you'd have to start shaving things off
yeah no you're doing significant pruning
great question so the sum of these
things get Krunk hated because you end
up doing this and then at this one you
don't have to go any further
right so the moment so it's not any to
the end simply because you don't have to
you never have to to put it put down
another queen if the first two queens
conflict with each other right so so
you're likely did actually went back on
Thursday at about this time yesterday we
were kind of going over the 4x4 and in
we would put one we didn't put a queen
down we kind of went over and we said oh
this disk lorry can't work because
because there's a queen on this row
already you know this clearly can't work
because it's a queen like one away right
so there's no reason to go deeper you
you would go and raise to n if you only
did the conflict check after you put 8
after you put n queens down right if you
put all n queens down sort of close your
eyes put in queens down and then ran a
conflict check then and then did that
over and over over and over it would be
n raised to n but that's not what we're
doing right what we're doing is if you
if you look at the code we're saying if
this is this is an important a statement
actually thanks for the question dad is
pruning your search and that is making
it significantly less than n raise to n
and nice exercise right I remember what
I said about opportunity for homework
and when I get questions a nice exercise
is to go to eight eight raise to 8 and
then figure out what whether it's eight
raise to 8 I'm sorry go to the 8 Queens
problem
and figure out what that number is in
terms of the number of times you're
actually checking for no conflict so
count the number of times not the number
of solutions because but the number of
times no conflicts is being called and
you'll find that it's significantly less
than a trace to eight okay because
you're pruning the search the way that
this what technically it's called
pruning the search I hi up in the tree
okay that's that that's the technical
term for it alright good any other
questions
all right so we're done with with eight
Queens and n Queens